and Charlie Angela is at Westminster
covering this for us Charlie adding
insult to injury this morning the
British press not pulling his punches
not at all Cyril no it's been 24 hours
of Mayhem for this government and the
newspaper headlines are scathing the
mirror says utter chaos government on
the brink with a picture of uh Liz truss
in Parliament while the sun is saying
broken detailing that she was heckled by
her own MPS while the other Murdoch
paper the times they're saying she's
facing more turmoil after sacking
Braverman now as you heard Sue Ella
bravaman resigned and in her resignation
letter didn't pull any punches going on
the attack saying that the government is
not facing up to its Manifesto pledges
she's been replaced by Grant schrapps
who did not back Liz truss in her
leadership bid but is now her right-hand
man and all that happened before the
vote on fracking which was tabled by the
labor party last night now
conservative MPS were told they couldn't
vote as they wished they had to vote
against it as a test of loyalty to the
government but that instruction was
changed at the last minute and that is
when chaos ensued allegations of pushing
and shoving as MPS were forced into the
voting Lobby the chief Whip and her
Deputy who were responsible for making
sure that MPS really vote in line with
their party's wishes felt undermined and
allegedly verbally resigned on the spot
the Prime Minister was then seen by one
MP briefly losing her security detail as
she pursued the chief whip Wendy Morton
through Parliament to try and persuade
her not to quit and in the early hours
of this morning a statement from number
10 saying both the chief Whip and her
Deputy were staying in their positions
and the Prime Minister had full
confidence in them but by then the
damage had been done the prime minister
is being accused of losing control of
her party and already we're seeing the
number of conservative MPS who are
openly calling for her to quit ticking
up by the minute when I woke up this
morning six MPS had sent their letters
to the 1922 committee we're now looking
at about nine so the question seems to
be not when she will not whether she
will exit but when Sarah well look many
people are predicting her demise this
morning whether it's commentators
whether it's politicians from both sides
of the aisle is there nonetheless a
scenario where she hangs on to power to
you think
well I mean her transport secretary has
been doing the media around this morning
and said that she does still believe
that Liz trust will lead the
conservative party in the next general
election but she is very much in the
minority and I think the next 24 hours
will be absolutely critical for her now
in those 24 hours we're going to see uh
suela bravaman give a resignation
statement and it's no secret that the
two women we're really at odds with each
other Braverman wanted to tighten the
UK's immigration policy trust wanted to
loosen it so we can expect braverman's
statement to heal even more pressure on
the Prime Minister we just heard that
the labor party has tabled an urgent
question in Parliament to ask why
bravaman resigns so there's going to be
some uncomfortable answers
um elicited there we also know that the
1922 committee which is responsible for
deciding on conservative leadership
contests is going to meet later today
and number 10 has said that it is going
to discipline those conservative MPS who
voted against the government last night
despite the chaos so that's going to
cause even more Discord within the party
so just to put this in some perspective
this trust has been in the job for six
weeks and in that time she's seen the
pound plummet she's had to reverse most
of her policy program she's had to sack
her Finance Minister and now she's seen
her interior Minister resign now back to
your question the one thing that could
be working in her favor is the lack of
consensus within the conservative party
who could should or would replace her as
a leader and that should be buying her
some time yeah Charlie you say the next
24 hours are critical for the British
prime minister you'll be there watching
it for us reporting on it for us every
step of the way thank you